[Applause]
welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio some of the big issues
in the national football league and
there was a report that came out
yesterday from the athletic vincent
bonsanor who covers the rams for the
athletic reporting that there has been
discussion among league personnel of the
possibility of the
chargers relocating permanently to
london peter look i'm skeptical about
that as a viable possibility
um what's your first reaction when you
think of
the chargers or really any team
relocating on a permanent basis to
london
i think we're at least four years away
from it i think it would be an
inconvenient
uh
to say the least
um thing right now if the chargers were
to actively consider and i have no idea
whether they are
were to actively consider uh moving to
london instead of los angeles and
there's two important factors at play
here
the nfl has its collective bargaining
agreement uh which obviously will expire
in 2021
early in 2021 so they're working right
now to get a new cba done could that
happen a year or two in advance it could
but usually deals like this don't get
done until the last minute and i've
always felt that there's no way a
collective bargaining agreement could
get done or there's no way a team could
move
to
london
until a collective bargaining agreement
got done because there isn't any
provision
to ask
a player or a team of players to play in
a different country on a different
continent
than to play in the united states in
north america
so the nfl pa is going to have something
to say about this number one
and and in order to get the momentum to
have one of these teams move it's a
gigantic process at the absolute
earliest i think it'd be 2022 but
probably 2023 is more realistic so it's
four years away i just i think it is a
little bit abrupt it would surprise me
if this really had legs but we'll see
what happens and the other thing is mike
the reason that i think that this is
really a cloudy situation is that you
keep hearing
uh that the uh the chargers are not uh
you know having a great experience
selling psl's and trying to fill their
their home games at this new stadium in
los angeles so we'll see what happens
yeah and that that is such a key aspect
to this because there's a 20-year lease
for the chargers to play at the stadium
that rams owner stan cronkie is
developing he's not going to let them
out of that lease every once in a while
we're here oh the chargers go to st
louis they go to san diego they go here
no they're not going anywhere they have
a lease that stan kroenke needs them to
honor because he needs the revenue from
those games to help pay for this 5
billion
5 billion dollar complex that he's
building in inglewood so that takes the
charges out of the mix immediately as
far as i'm concerned then there's the
reality and this isn't mentioned in the
story on the athletic.com website the
jaguars have been viewed as the team
that kind of has the unofficial dibs on
london that if they want to go if shot
khan wants to move the team to london
they're going to find a way to make it
work i still think it is a long way from
happening if it ever happens peter the
other cynical view on this getting this
idea out there now and not attaching it
to the jaguars so people in jacksonville
don't freak out attaching it to a team
where it's completely unrealistic and or
the fan base wouldn't care to have their
team attached to it and the chargers fan
base wouldn't care the idea that that
maybe the nfl is trying to use this
possibility as just another way to
squeeze the union to agree to 17 games
because if you do 17 you get 16 neutral
site games you have eight games that get
played in london and nobody has to move
and maybe as they're trying to get the
players to understand how it's going to
be
it's either going to be 17 games or it's
going to be somebody moves and i don't
think any nfl player wants to be on a
team that plays in london
it's so hard to expand from four mike
over in london because the logistics are
so hard look the green bay packers have
never played in london teams fight
playing in london worse than they fight
being on hard knocks so you're right
there's a lot of roadblocks ahead
check out more p-f-t-o-t on yahoo sports
throughout the 2019 nfl season
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports